so you absolutely destroyed that light
goal way things are going I'm probably
going to end up bold before next year
but I've got to beit unreasonable now
30,000 likes before the next part of the
story which is the Neo Heroes Arc in
around a month from now and I'll shave
my head after that this part here though
the psychic sisters Arc probably has
some of the greatest moments from
throughout the series it's not
necessarily on like the same destructive
level that the previous monster
Association Arc was on but it
comedically had me curling over in
pained laughter everything is just
brilliant and I'm a glaz the goat Morata
and one with this video so damn hard
this whole Arc just feels like season
one with how the pacing is and just the
world breaking level of sight hamor
everything that comes his way is just
played off like a complete joke of
course remember to subscribe if you are
new on here and want content just like
this but for a variety of different
series for now time to sit back and
enjoy the video kicking things back off
right outside a large apartment in the
new hero Association base butterfly DX
Forte and chain and Toad decide to visit
at the new freak of a neighbor they call
out to him and ring his doorbell
thinking he might be a rocky they can
outshine as more experienced Heroes to
their surprise the door swings open and
King stands before them and Stelling
fear into the trio as they come to the
realization that scam isn't home at all
elsewhere throughout the one punch man
world and amidst the destroyed landscape
of the previous battle site a lone
helicopter spots a certain hero down
below and rumaging through a sea of
rubble Pig God is searching for
something confusing everyone in the
helicopter close by the weird Meetup is
spotted by black is who is currently
hiding inside of the rubble with all of
the heroes in the helicopter yelling out
to Peg God telling him that he needs to
rest the S-Class hero decides to run off
randomly and of course black s notices
Peg God running in his Direction and
hides to not be found the representative
annoyed at the S-Class Hero's
self-centered nature is then met by the
a Class Hero ear who claims he'll take
the job of capturing big pig God
claiming that all he needs is 5 minutes
to finish off the wounded Pig ear rushes
forward as he gets closer the a class
comments on the pathetic state of all of
these so-called pellars from what he's
heard they were all taken out by the
hero Hunter they're spoiled and
neglected their training getting up to
the large hero he demands that Peg God
return back to the base or face him to
gain his freedom overhearing what the
dude's saying the representative becomes
anxious over how this happens every damn
time with Heroes suddenly something
moves amongst the rubble nearby
revealing itself the object turns out to
be none other than a severely reduced EV
natural water its appearance doesn't
phase ear but stuns Peg God who knows of
the monster's true capabilities ear then
nonchalant decides to deal with the
little monster first and launches his
boomerang only for the demon level
threat to shoot a beam of water that
penetrates through the boomerang and his
throat with complete ease black s who
was hiding within a few feet of the
group sees the scuffle and is shocked to
see that his fellow monster is still
alive without hesitation Pig God then
quickly swallows evil natural water
seemingly ending the monster's existence
randomly a plethora of water beams then
shoot out of Peg God in every direction
concerned the representative asks what
the hell he just swallowed however pegot
explains that it's okay now because the
monster is fully digested the D tries to
get the S-Class hero to return and get
examined by The Docks but he points out
that the helicopter can't even hold him
instead he actually intends to visit a
Ramen Shop walking off now he points out
that a survey of the area should
probably be done to find any surviving
monsters over with black s and realizing
that they're extremely low on Cell
stocks he runs away deeper into the
destroyed area and finds somewhere to
hide as he walks he can't help but be
shocked at the monster association's
downfall he continues his search for
something to eat and gain a few extra
lives when suddenly he sees s any
distance Sait himself is Overjoyed at
the situation as after a few days of
searching he's finally found the remains
of his destroyed apartment knowing that
this man is he hthy black is hides in
sheer Terror after everything the last
person he wanted to bump into was the
naked man who knocked out the awakened G
with a single punch to his horror the
Jew's attention is moved towards the now
much smaller overgrown Rover looking
down on the trio now black s is baffled
that somehow POI survived as he watches
the monoliths of strength Tower over the
pup he can only feel sorry for the poor
thing and also realizes that it would be
wise for him to leave bizarrely and just
before leaving he sees Sarma stick his
hand out and pick up Rover he notices
that instead of instantly killing the
monster saitam is treating Rover like an
animal thinking about why a man of this
strength wouldn't deal with a threat he
assumes that the dude is the sort of guy
who probably avoids needless violence
realizing that this could actually be
his one chance at survival black hair
starts to fixate on what his next action
should be meanwhile Jos and scarm are
stuck in conversation over how long he's
been a fan of dogs for with a letter
telling him that it's actually just a
recent occurrence Jus agrees that they
are extremely cute but before he can
worry about the cost of feeding Rover
has watched beeps letting him know that
he's needed at the hero Association
still stuck in thought black his
believes that even if the monsters come
back there's no safer place than under
the protection of Sarma sucking up his
pride black is eventually leaps out from
behind the rubble and attempts to join
the Bal King's group of Muppets a little
while later saam is seen yelling at the
newcomer telling him to stop following
him as right now he can barely take care
of this dog let alone some weird monkey
thing Blakey speaks up and tries to
convince him by saying that he'll help
out with chores but after scam begins to
walk off sticks with the idea of hiding
low as his monkey wondering if the
apartment even allowed pits in the first
place scammer just assumes that he could
put up a dogghouse outside exciting
black is questioning the cardr sa asks
if he's seen a oneeyed monster around
these parts thinking that he possibly
means jro Juro black is just claims that
it must have been taken out by one of
tatsumaki's larger attacks obviously you
know he's not even been talking about
guo he's talking about Monaco right
there which is quite funny you know the
oneeyed monster miss good old Monaco man
I wish he'd pop back up into the story
getting closer s points out that he can
see it now his new home blowing away
with the tremendous size the little
monster finally feels like this is a
place he doesn't need to watch his back
inside of meanwhile inside of the hero
Association headquarters a presentation
is given to a select few Rich members of
the public about the new apartment
complexes green and cing eyebrows talk
to each other about how it's obvious the
association is targeting the rich first
green knows that if money is able to buy
safety the recent influx of rich people
who are willing to pay for it is
increasing C points out that it's
probably because monster attacks are on
unprecedented levels these days even
disaster level demons pop up more than
twice a month now the presentation
mentions that the apartments are
impervious to monster attacks and only a
Class Heroes or above with a proven
track record can live here as residents
while simultaneously being body guards
taking in all of the speculative
information the crowd doesn't
reciprocate these same feelings they
know that even if they're living with
Heroes they're still human just like
them and can be injured they can easily
wear themselves out or get caught up in
an accident that in their eyes certainly
can't be called Safety since in the unee
of how weak the human frame is the
presenter moves to a new topic the hero
apartment's secret weapon designed by M
Knight and using an AI to anticipate
coordinate and execute the appropriate
response it is claimed by middle Knight
that this comprehensive defense system
does a more effective job at defending
the base than all of the aass heroes
combined cutting through all of each
chatter randomly the B's alarm system
detects something nearby and activates
outside the headquarters sight armor
overgrown Rover and black has arrive at
a large steel entrance Door the defense
system sensing the two monsters
calculates their strength and sends out
a level one response as the entrance
door opens a gigantic robot walks out
and confronts the trio without
hesitation the robot attempts to
annihilate the two monsters with a
thundering left smash confused sa blocks
the attack destroying the arm before
jumping up into the sky and completely
shattering it with a simple slap this in
turn annihilates the level one defense
system causing the building's AI bot to
readjust its calculations and send out a
lot of level four robots just like
before the robots launched their attack
firing hundreds of blasts in the
direction of the trio black is and Rover
somehow managed to slip their way
through the blasts just before Sama who
you know was completely unconcerned with
the level increase adjusted these stupid
robots with a quick smack obviously this
completely destroys all of the robots
and activates the entire base's defense
system inside and freaking out over the
current battle going on right next to an
entrance the hero Association sends out
an emergency call for several Heroes to
deal with the threat confusedly they try
and search for the exit inside of this
new large complex eventually they head
towards the South and find the correct
entrance doorway however as they rush
outside the representative sees sarm and
asks what the hell just happened out
here so tries to tell him that well they
all just randomly exploded but gets cut
off when another one complains that
these robots took 9 billion each to
develop now terrified of dealing with
the financial repercussions of his
actions sa weekly states that they all
just simply exploded obviously the
officials don't believe him in the
slightest and ask for every single
detail possible on what just happened
here cutting the representative off and
backing up the Bold King a familiar
voice tells him that he's telling the
truth of course it's no one other than
King who states it he saw it too all
these robots just randomly exploded
while all of the representatives are
caught up on King's appearance Sait
approaches his mate and gives him back
his video game console albeit completely
broken even though it was you know like
him who actually broke it in the first
place remember back when he got mad and
I'm pretty sure it was when he got mad
and he over clicked it too hard breaking
it now man's trying to pass it off as
damage from the recent battle it's a
it's a genius move but s he just he just
can't own up for his mistakes it's so
funny on top of that and curing his
anxiety King doesn't mind in the
slightest and head only stopped by his
apartment earlier to see if he wanted to
jam out to give her watching nearby
Forte is surprised to see King talking
with a complete nobody as the hero
wonders like who the hell he is it's
shown that after a lot of trials and
tribulations sa has now been promoted to
a class rank 39 over in the control room
of the new headquarters a few of the
workers talk about how much money was
poured into the design of this place
they think middle Knight's done a sloppy
job as with his robots malfunctioning
like that it's throwing billions of
taxpayer dollars down the drain of
course you know they're talking about
billions of Yen so it's like hundreds
and hundreds of millions probably one of
the guys notes that he's going to share
the image data from the security cameras
with booy so he's interested to find out
what excuse he's going to come up with
this time somewhere else in deep thought
booy can't understand how level four
through 10 of his robots were completely
destroyed what's more the one who did it
was a complete loser from the hero
Association Class A ranked 39 caped baly
glancing over his data he can see that
within 65 days saama or as they know him
caped baly has risen through the ranks
extremely quickly that it's actually
wild when you think about how long this
Series has been going for for us and
since the time saitam you know did his
test I guess back in season 1 it's been
only 65 days that blew my mind when I
first read this I just the fact it's
been like 10 years hasn't it like at
this point it's got to have been it's
crazy anyway anyway moving forth needing
to Source more information the bucktooth
genius cracks into the association's
database and discovers that sight armor
has helped in a bunch of the most recent
battles confused on while he was ranked
up so quickly he finds some hidden
remarks about how early on the man
absolutely destroyed the physical test
becoming the new record holder for it
seeing how easily he destroyed his robot
Botho judges that sight armmer is
probably stronger than even an S-Class
hero and decides to track him just in
case he becomes a future enemy H I
wonder what Botho possibly got up his
sleeve he's a bit cheeky it feels like
is this the first time that we actually
see bofo as well I'm pretty sure that it
properly is I can't remember but I'm
pretty sure it is coming back to two
days ago in an emergency meeting held
with only Jos flashy flash sweet mask
zombie man sing gu and such present big
search suggests that the recent events
during the monster Association incident
are linked with the prophecy that the
Earth is in danger he asks that until
they can confirm their official standing
to keep all information confidential Jos
immediately agrees but zombie man
wonders why he even wants to keep things
secret this late in the game fleshy
flesh thinks that they should remain
cautious as even heroes have begun
reporting that anybody at any moment can
just transform into a monster already
knowing this info sit says that it's
precisely because of this reason that
they need to be certain about a way of
fighting it before doing anything
publicly sigar points out that that
revealing this info too early could
actually create a form of mass hysteria
due to a widespread fear and anxiety
over not knowing who might become the
next threat having an extremely tight
schedule along with his pants sweet mask
asks for more information on what they
already have as he doesn't have a single
clue what they were actually even
talking about J sputs in with a stack of
notes and remarks to the group that he
needs to sit aside exactly 3 hours to
discuss sa's activities during the
battle realizing that he probably needs
to put Jos last such asks zombie man to
discuss what was told to him during his
battle against homeless Emperor sitting
there zombie man mentions that while
homeless Emperor was still human he was
given a divine power by someone called
God such sweet mask and SAR are
surprised At The Mention Of God while
Jos and flashy flash who weren't too
surprised state that he had previously
encountered something that tried to
offer power and spoke to him
telepathically the gods stated a su that
if the vessel who took this power wasn't
worthy then they would face forfeit CH
so man who you know like fought homeless
Emperor obviously remembers and lets
everyone know that in his final moments
homeless Emperor seems to be hearing
someone or addressing someone in person
fleshy flesh takes this info and the
stuff that was given to him by God and
is able to figure out that what killed
homeless Emperor was probably the same
being sweet mask speaks up and proposes
that this God might just be a leader of
the monster Association after all the
so-called Juro turned out to be a human
isper FY denies this as in his opinion
it would be weirded that only a select
few Cadre were granted this power out of
the entire base the enemies that they
just faced wouldn't be strong enough to
Force Blast and chasing this thing
through the shadows of SpaceTime looking
at such now fleshy asks for any info on
what's actually going on with him not un
Lally saying anything flashy reiterates
what was told to him by blast during the
previous battle causing s to reveal that
he has actually been helping keep blast
headd in for the past 20 years Blast has
been continuously fighting against the
one they call God
blast along with his Intergalactic
Partners had been searching for a
mysterious Cube that could turn humans
into monsters this Cube was handed down
over time as a kind of communication
device that somewhat allowed an
individual to communicate with God blast
was specifically collecting these with
his boys and trying to analyze them
however 2 years ago during the infamous
battle in which blast took on the outer
centipede he came into contact with God
directly of course like most other
S-Class Heroes who have been prompted by
God blast refus to power and actually
ped himself against God at that point in
time the association wasn't able to hold
a candle against such an opponent even
wor everyone working together to start
with not a single sensor they've created
has been able to detect the being once
they realized that it would probably be
safer to have everyone stay unaware of
it blast took off into the expanse of
time and tried his best to protect
everyone flashy stand with the current
information he's receiving figured that
the top ranking hero would have a good
reason for not showing himself do you
know though man thinks you know
completely differently jumping into the
conversation he lets them know that if
they had just spoken about it sooner
saam AKA caped baly could have resolved
this already actually a goat for
standing up for his man right here sit
tries to deny this Rock Solid
information by explaining the only blast
is able to battle God because of
SpaceTime manipulation ability laying
his trap card on the table Jos asks if
that is indeed so he after all wasn't
able to fit this into his onepage report
so instead he decided to bring a spefic
specific tactic up here that he knows
will work beginning his long held off
rant the cyborg tells them each and
every detail on what happened in the
fight between scammer and go along with
his own fate and that of all of the
other Heroes after the gring 4-Hour
discussion comes to an end with sweet
mask leaving due to scheduling problems
everyone is exhausted still they all
claim that Genesis Intel is pretty damn
wild seconding I can't even fear them
how it's possible for them to fly to
Jupiter destroy the entire planet then
fly back then on top of that the time
travel just makes it all completely fly
over their heads such mentions that if
it is true they must confer with sight
armor for its authenticity yes and like
we already know Jos remarks that Sait
has no memory of the events leading
flashy flash to call js's explanation a
lie enraging the cyborg zombie man
instead points out that they could
confer with G and confirm it that way
again though siga explains that the
apparent shock from the final punch made
him lose his memory from throughout the
battle with no definitive info at all s
states that the one thing they can
confirm is that the interactions with
God's Dimension is rapidly increasing
blast assumed that it's possible there
might be something in their world's
Dimension drain him here either way sit
continues explaining that blast will
soon return and until then their top
priorities are unity and solidarity
having completed their meeting Jos
abruptly leaves saying that if they do
hear anything from blast they need to
contact saitama aka Mr caped Baldi
immediately still super cocky flashy
tail search to let blast know that he
needs to hurry up and finish his current
fight so they can finally throw down
before also leaving the place sitting
there himself zombie man suddenly
remembers back to Dr genus's words about
someone losing their hair in exchange
for removing the limiter realizing that
it might have been the Caped Baldi
zombie man gets ready for the impending
future down a nearby hallway flashy
thought that up until now caped baly was
positioned under Goos after this meeting
and seen the dude's intense devotion
towards sight armmer it makes him think
that it's possible he might be that guy
elsewhere and as sweet mask makes his
way towards his next scheduled meeting
he can't help but think for Jos to be so
captivated by caped body he must have
what it takes what it takes to be the
ideal hero being driven through a
Mountain Road Fuki is asked by eyelashes
why on Earth does she want to go to this
place anyway looking actually banging
right now Fuki replies that she plans to
meet someone and there's a slight chance
things will turn violent elsewhere in
our city sweet mask is approached by a
director of a new upcoming Idol group
this idle group The bubbly boys are a
group of seven Strong high school age
students with two of them having already
passed the C-Class hero exam having
explained this all to him the director
hopes that sweet mask will be able to
give them some advice in surviving this
Cutthroat entertainment industry and
concerned with these pathetic nerds
sweet tells them that they have zero
appeal none so don't talk to him he
isn't interested in phonies instead he's
entirely fixated on looking at his phone
more specifically the security camera
footage from 2 days ago which shows a
caped baly destroying the base's
defenses after hearing harsh words from
the hero that they've based their entire
existence on the members of the group
start arguing with him to his annoyance
he tries explaining to the idiots that
the title of hero isn't something that
can be used as a stepping stone that way
of thinking is exactly while the
agency's already saying that the group's
difficult to handle wondering what they
would do if sweet was a monster and it
appeared in front of them like this the
group claims that they' lay him out at s
onone and he shouldn't be looking down
on them the bubbly boys beginning to
crack up laughing without warning the
pathetic boys feel an overwhelming chill
that startles them into silence sweet
musk explains that it's their instincts
warning them of how they are twoo
biologically different menacingly
staring at them he sternly lets them
know how disgusting they truly are none
of them AB beautiful beautiful like him
the Caped body and all his overwhelming
power speaking of the man himself over
inside his apartment sa finally meets
with and greets fellow aass Heroes chain
and Toad butterfly DX and Forte after
finding out that saam is older than him
for claims that he is the senior of the
apartment because he moved in first saam
however notes that the place only opened
2 weeks ago moving past the teething
troubles Zama greets his new neighbor
and tells him about how his place was
recently destroyed yet once he became a
class and King told him about this
shelter he moved in randomly chain and
Toad removes his Fury hair to take a
quick sip of the tea then casually puts
it back on confused SAA asks what the
hell just happened big butterfly
explains that due to Chen toad being
extremely plain of a person he wasn't
popular in the Hero rankings in an
attempt to fix that he started wearing
the head gear to develop a sort of you
know character thanks to these smart
tricks he was able to become just
slightly popular with the kids when it
comes to the bearer of this info
butterfly DX well he assumes Sait
already knows of his skills so there's
no need to explain them yet and to his
complete confusion Sait notes that he
doesn't have a clue who he is but he is
Charmed this physically breaks butterfly
who claims that he's been on TV a lot
and is pretty famous online too
strolling off he tells them or to hold
on just just for a second bursting back
into the room fully dressed in his hero
uniform he excitedly says that this is
what he usually looks like still Sait
has to explain to him that his place has
only had public broadcast so for the
past 2 or 3 years he's only watched
disaster and Weather Channels Plus for a
semi naked butterfly sa finds him
overtly hairy and asks him to not start
[__] in his room next up Forte
introduces himself and says that he uses
music or more specifically the Rhythm to
help him fight in battle on top of that
he remarks that they put him in a
fashion magazine once however he doesn't
even care about that so I don't remains
unimpressed though wondering how working
up a rhythm each time he fights even
helps him annoyed with this Forte
screams out in anger and threatens sarm
to a fight outside leaving the room in
preparation to throw down saama looks
down to notice that just outside his
door black and Rover are there thinking
that he should probably start sitting up
a dog house he all of a sudden has an
even brighter idea then in ways you know
light in his workload sa proposes the
plan of having the loser of his upcoming
battle take care of his pet
walking out themselves now Forte notices
the monkey looking thing and cruy picks
it up by his head's antenna butter fly
can't help but notice the weird look of
it as well and wonders if it's a sort of
monster hearing this theis realizes that
he needs to continue pretending to be a
monkey if he wants to survive having
taken a look at the so-called pit forter
agrees with saam's proposal of making
the loser take care of them down in the
association's parking lot now chain and
Toad and Butterfly DX watches the two a
Class Heroes begin to face off for cocky
tells his opponent that he might end up
getting hurt so no hard feelings either
way bro to which sa States the same
thing and pleads for him to not big to
become his disciple once he wins chain
to notes that moving to a rhythm isn't a
strange technique even First Rate
martial artists learn to do this however
if you dismiss for's unique fighting
style that has been attained through
countless battles as a performer then
that fool would be in for a world of
pain Excavating his music VTE begin
showing off his unique style of fighting
with rhythm randomly though as he does
this sa tries screaming something out to
him due to his headphones though Forte
doesn't hear it and is run down by a car
that it just pulled into the parking
lots quickly getting out of the car to
check what the hell they just ran into
it's revealed to be the blizzard group
who were heading to this unknowing
location earlier noticing someone
getting out of the car c makes sure to
let her know to apologize to this random
dude later on curious as to why size
hamers is even at the hero Association
Fuki questions what the hell he's even
doing here meanwhile in an underground
parking area a mysterious person exits
their dope ass [__] car and is welcomed
by the hero Association staff members
being in the vicinity Fuki senses that
man's presence and tells s Hammer to
come with her turning around she grants
a permission to accompany them the Fuki
group into the association confusing the
hell out of scammer grabbing his pants
black is asks scammer what they should
do looking over and realizing that
technically he has beaten Forte hands
over black sperm and overgrown Rover to
butterfly dick before leaving with Fuki
and her group moving into the
association's base now the Fuki group
makes the way down to the special
interment facility given the inmates
number they intend to visit to the
receptionist it's revealed to them that
the inmate has already been visited by
someone else following this maing they
have been immediately transferred to
another location due to this the
receptionist lets them know that they
can't visit this person however would
this been an emergency for Buu demands
to be taken there straight away down on
floor B3
the mysterious man is led to a gigantic
jailing cell opening the door the guard
exclaims that it's perfectly safe as
this person has been highly medicated
inside it's showing that the Mastermind
behind the monster Association psychos
has been incapacitated and restrained
making his way inside this random dude
says that according to what he was able
to surveil during the previous battle
this woman was able to fight on even
grounds with touch Mar for their
organization she is an extremely
valuable person with a few extraordinary
abilities he thanks the higher up
members of the hero Association for
handing her over to them to which it's
revealed that they have already stripped
her of all of her human rights and
labeled her as a monster they are now
technically free to do whatever they
please with her after coming up to her
the man claims that psychos is a sample
that will greatly help in progressing
the Suki yomi's research upon hearing
the name Suki yomi pyos becomes slightly
alert and uses her telekinesis to
assault the man who also appears to be
an esper and quickly blocks her attack
figuring that the medication wasn't
exactly the greatest this dude launches
a Counterstrike and renders her
unconscious with one blast looking at
her full limp he stops his attack and
notes that they cannot damage her
precious brain inside it of course is
the OD over third eye that they have
heard so much about an eye that allows
one to take a glimpse into the future
one of the representatives asks if he
should you know like deal some more to
her as they they have some fantastic
facilities right here turning and
revealing his true self now this man
exclaims that it's fine they'll perform
a very thorough examination on her once
they get back to his lab meanwhile and
while taking a massive elevator that
leads underground saitama at the
blizzard group head towards the
mysterious man while on their way there
Fuki recalls her encounter with psychos
during the monster Association incident
as they were about to battle Fuki
addressed her as the former vice
president psychos of the third eye she
tried appealing to her human side and
asked for the fellow esper to surrender
herself peacefully otherwise it might
harm her actual life spazzing out and
pure anger over being told what to do by
this absolute witch again psychos
angrily said that Fuki got desperate and
sealed of her powers when they were
students now just when she was about to
rise up and be the strongest in the
world she stands in front of her once
again hearing this Fuki agrees and says
that yes she used to be a self-centered
person but back in the day when psychos
proposed the idea of humanity
extermination while they were still in a
group class called the soci iy for
Supernatural research everyone hated
that idea Fuki though all she could
think of was an overwhelming desire to
pass her sister and stand on top of the
world as she completed that there
wouldn't be a need for anyone else at
the top watching the high school psychos
more Fuki came to hate who she was she
despised that she tried to steal her
followers away from her on that day she
realized that psychos was her enemy and
enemies must be crushed screaming that
this time Fuki will be crushed psychos
SPS a flurry of sharp Zone object down
in the ground below somehow powering up
on an unprecedented level that we
haven't seen Fuki at before apart from
maybe against you know POI Fuki is then
SE flying up into the sky through the
rubble and commencing a 1 V one battle
against her old schoolmates in a
flashback a young psychos is scene
telling Fuki about the increased
membership and their group and the
invisible hand from a nearby Town
wanting to pick a fight with them over
time it's shown that the Invisible Hand
instead offered to work underneath them
wondering if she's actually getting
stronger herself pyos commends Fuki for
having powers that dwarf her already
strong abilities pyos at this point was
actually only able to lift a single
human while Fuki was able to lift an
entire 18 wheeel truck later in a
library psychos has seen sudden a new
ability called the third eye that allows
her to see into the future with this
ability she thinks that she might be
able to predict the future just like the
great prophet shabaa on top of that it
might allow her and Fuki to finally
overthrow her evil older sister however
the future psychos then sees drives her
insane to a point she can't even seem to
understand that this this is the future
she will go into mentally insane now the
next day at school the overwhelming pain
of his future caused her to scream out
that all of their future plans are
pointless explaining it all to Fuki she
instead proposed the idea of destroying
everyone that way at least the whole
human race will be able to start over
and it won't become the disaster it's
certain to be back to the moment where
they were confronting each other during
the monster Association incident and
already wakened psychos Was Defeated and
captured by Fuki who wanted to know the
source of her Madness it's actually
crazy to think that somehow Fuki managed
to capture the person that was putting
her sister like pushing her sister to
the Limit I I don't understand it either
way either way what was it that she saw
in the future catching the falling
psychos In Her Arms Fuki wonders what
changed her she was never a tough person
placing her hand on her old friend's
head she senses a mysterious presence
floating above them that sent chills
down her spine back in the present the
blizzard group and saitama finally
arrive at psycho's internment unit just
as she is about to be taken away by that
random man Fuki informs everyone present
that the visitation is over and they
need to evacuate the room immediately
due to the information about psychos
being moved and if tataki ends up
fighting out about it she'll come in and
finish her off immediately instantly
following that warning the roof above
Fuki is destroyed and tataki drops into
the room to finish her job pointing her
finger down and questioning why she's
alive tataki attempts to bury psychos
and Rubble luckily Fuki is able to react
in time managing to put an energy orb
around psychos seeing the random try and
attack her tataki with just like a
complete glance sends the random dude
shooting into the wall nearby Fuki then
screams for all of the representatives
to escape back to the surface and
commands her guys to start attacking her
sister getting ready to send a blast in
her sister's Direction it suddenly skips
back in time to identitate between the
two there t explained that the same guys
who captured her when she was younger
and now after psychos even though she's
a monster tataki finds it immoral to
hand her over to anyone from that group
instead she actually plans to work in
combination with Fuki while making it
look like they aren't even together
skipping back to the fight the random
isper who managed to survive tatar's
blow gets back up and knocks out the
fleeing Representatives then destroys
the room's cameras slowly powering up he
expresses a desire to make all three of
the girls into souvenirs as all of the
espers began powering up sending Rubble
flying scammer tries butting in all he
came here to do was actually complain to
tataki for destroying his apartment but
it's obvious now that she doesn't have a
sorry bone in her body while pretending
to hold off her sister fuku remarks that
she's lucky saarma joined her she knows
he has a great strength within him and
is even playing dumb purposefully not
realizing that he defeated g s tries to
say that he honestly doesn't remember
but it's not like she was even listening
to him in the first place she fought go
too and it was obvious that he was
someone who had reached his Peak and
then ascended it if scammer did truly
take him down then he must have ascended
as well Fuki she gave up on being the
strongest a long time ago and because of
that she can make the distinction
between those who are and an ascended
due to the powerful psychic clash
between tatsumaki and the man from suomi
the ground beneath saam violently cracks
open and he falls down to the floor
below much of auky shock down on an even
lower level now of the associate iation
s confronts many like hundreds of demon
level beans who have been detained there
laying there he wonders what the hell
this part of the base even is noticing
that the base is keeping monsters as
pets he takes this information and
presumes that it's probably sweet to
have a dog or two in his Apartments
elsewhere it's revealed that this month
inide of the world of one punch man has
had an alltime high of monster disasters
a random rich girl in a date notes that
if tons more of these monsters keep
appearing then people might not be able
to go outside the though he knows he's
safe the higher ranking Heroes all
protect this area they have an even
higher level security than any upscale
neighborhood the facilities the
association provides are on par if not
better than any other place and they've
got even more planned there isn't any
annoying traffic and it might even
become the capital W hearing all of this
quells the girl's fears of death however
after she places her tea down notices
that it's shaking feeling what surely
isn't an earthquake the dude denies all
thoughts of it as this facility is
constructed with state of the-art
earthquake restraints as it seems to
come to a stop a sudden clash between
tatsumaki and the Mysterious dude
creates a powerful earthquake that
knocks the rich people off their feet
over in the control center hell is
literally breaking loose as they try and
quickly discover the location of this
shaking noticing that it's coming from
the experimental monster floor The Man
In Charge screams out to get some Heroes
down there back in the battle between
espers and noticing that he still a
slight disadvantage tataki mocks him
asking if the poor little guinea pig
ever thought he s a chance
getting distracted for a moment tataki
notices her sister fainting after trying
to reopen the hole in the floor in
actuality though it's revealed that
previously before coming here this
random dude had implanted a sleeping
tablet in fi's Daily supplements taking
new hostage now he threatens to break
the deadly poison one he put inside of
her next if tatsumaki comes any closer
enraged but still able to think on the
spot tatsumaki realizes that there's
most likely a spy in the manufacturer of
the base or someone in her sister's
group complimenting her list in skills
the male isper demands that tatsumaki
not resist joking that he needs to make
her slightly easier to carry tatsumaki
is suddenly forced into a binding of
psychic power while holding her down he
explains that the espers are a defective
species that need to go extinct throwing
up his other hand the dude proceeds to
open the containment cage of the demon
level monsters that are kept on the
floor beneath him he explains that no
one would care of both of these sisters
died due to tatsumaki's rage unleashing
all of these monsters here emerging from
the Fuki group the Spy then jumps up and
flies off to make his leave with this
mysterious man as the plasma field
holding back the monsters begins to
disappear all of the weake Fuki members
try and close the door but it just won't
work with a terrifying Screech all of
the demon level monsters slowly began
emerging from the floor below randomly
though all of the monsters explode and
saama burst through the floor's entrance
surprising everyone getting slightly
distracted for a moment kataki manages
to find a way free and breaks through
the mental restraints put on her body
instantly following this the suomi
member attempts to activate the poison
pill in sort of Fuki though to no avail
instead it's shown that tataki within
milliseconds of receiving her power back
had managed to find and neutralize that
pill she managed to do this by copying
the wavelength of her opponent's espers
telekinetic signals and turning the pel
into a needle thinner than a strand of
here following this tatsumaki pulls the
needle out of hii's body and then
directs it towards her enemy's face
throwing up his hands to stop it the
suomi member can do nothing as it
pierces through his hands and stabs
directly into his right eye noticing
that he somehow didn't die from the
attack tatsumaki menacingly threatens
him as she intends to ring his body
until all information on the suomi group
is revealed using her psychic abilities
tataki collapses the complete room and
on this dude and captures him inside a
huge Boulder sized asteroid the Spy
desperately tries to flee the scene but
tataki glances in his Direction and
sends him crashing into a nearby wall
knocking them out with the Suki yomi
members defeated and the situation
solved the blizzard group rushes to
their leader tsumaki furiously demands
that they shut their goddamn mouths and
scolds the entire group including Fuki
she demands that her younger sister
breaks all ties with them they were used
to take advantage of her and they just
got lucky this time in all reality
tataki knows that she can't protect them
all and needs to split her sister away
from them showing the love that they
have for their leader the Fuki group
demands to know why if they at least
explain it to them then maybe they can
figure out a countermeasure enraged with
their Defiance tataki sternly tells them
that it's because of this stupidity
their Leader's life was put in danger
Fuki doesn't need them anymore and in
her eyes all of them are just a nuisance
if they don't decide to leave now then
tataki threatens that she'll make sure
they can never work again Fuki screams
out for a sister to stop however the one
to grabbed the Esper's hand and put a
stop to this complete rage fist was no
one other than the Bal King asking what
the hell he's doing sa tells her that
the two sisters are just like each other
this this is going too far just to
lecture someone one in another place a
suddenly awakens in the hero Association
Hospital speaking of forte who was you
know obviously also put in hospital says
that he doesn't need to worry he's
perfectly safe here according to what
he's heard ear had L his guard down for
a moment and was taken out by a random
monster wondering who he actually is
forter introduces himself to ear as the
a rank number 31 hero and someone who's
at higher rank than him so they should
probably just get along forter himself
notes that he probably actually isn't in
the best state to judge someone right
now and still can't even comprehend how
his opponent took him down feeling
something on his neck himself and
noticing the change in his voice a
random doctor lets ear know that the
damage he received in battle was severe
to fix him they had to surgically
augment his voice box with some
mechanics the doctors claimed that they
specialists in cyborg science and were
requested personally by the Association
to help out with ear seeing that you
know he's being ignored here butterfly
DX asks Forte what's getting him so
riled up it's not like he should be
taking taking out his anger on others to
start with not listening to him Forte
just goes in a fat rant about how once
he leaves here he's going to get revenge
on that douchebag named s armor or
something that guy acted like a dumbass
but turned out to be one tricky genius
with an abnormal ability for asks his
boys if they all saw it as well scammer
was right there in front of him then
randomly out of absolutely nowhere he
was assaulted by an attack that sent him
straight to hospital on top of that his
ankle was broken and he has a crazy ass
Whiplash it's almost as if he was hit by
a car getting close to him both of for's
boys let him know that it was a car bro
plus he probably should stop using
headphones during battle as the guy you
know he was he was just trying to help
him out realizing how freaking stupid he
is now Forte asks them to forget about
everything he just said he honestly
thought he was just like tari and was
the owner of some cheat level psychic
abilities T which hearing that butterfly
remarks that if it was her he'd
definitely be dead bringing the trio
back to reality Forte wonders what the
hell the shaking was earlier knowing
some of the information butterfly DX
says that it was some monsters in the
jail house going rampant but we'll go
and Source some more info while he's
resting here meanwhile and after having
her hand grabbed by the big man himself
tataki asks if he's de or something as
she just told him to let go s replies
that he's just trying to get her to calm
the actual hell down causing the esper
to throw s through the association's
base looking at the force being exerted
on him plat wonders if this was the same
ability that sent Jos flying and tells
tataki that right now she's no different
powerwise from Fuki Fuki having heard
this screams out in horror not wanting
scammer to enrage her sister anymore
just straight up piss now tataki screams
from him to let go and begins trying to
twist the B man's body much to the spise
of the S Class Hero sa is able to endure
her attack making a question what in the
world's different about him chilling in
his own strength Dimension saama starts
to notice a subtle Twitch in his muscles
making Fuki think that he's easily able
to withstand her sister's full power
getting up close to him now tataki
remarks that she thought she'd seen him
somewhere before he's the B who's always
chilling with the demon cyborg confused
as to why he's here now she asks if he's
a part of the Fuki group as well un
concerned for the child trying to escape
his grasp Sait yells out for Fuki to
quickly evacuate everyone out of here
before his sister accidentally kills
them seen how cute saama is with foki
tataki with a look I'm sure I've never
even seen before questions if that's the
true reason as to why he's here now
taking this question as like what he
means exactly to Fuki s says that it's
not like he's a mate or companion or
even close friend you know he's just
simply an acquaintance of hers hearing
this news spoty flame within the heart
of habuki and drops her to the floor
completely unconscious looking hella
devious herself tataki asks why he'd get
so desperate just over a simple
acquaintance either way in her eyes she
needs to test his strength level to find
out if he truly deserves to be hanging
all over for boki like that which is
absolutely crazy man one or Mar you guys
are nuts for chucking that in there I
laugh so damn hard when I first saw that
part this whole part of the video like
so far is just unrealistically funny and
it just gets even better as we go like
each part is even better and better and
better I don't get a man it's unreal
like how continuously funny it is every
situation scer is in is like half
serious and just not at all like even
here he gets exactly what she's saying
and even gets repulsed at the idea of it
instead he exclaims that it's hers she's
the one dragging him around all the damn
time and just being a total pain God I
love the look of like the star eyed Fuki
in the background just glaring at him
anyways anyways amping himself up the
surroundings all began warping and
twisting to the power increase and
tataki psychic outputs above all of the
residents began freaking out over this
apparent brand new building already
suffering some damning issues in the
control room Geer yells out that the
elevator to get to the lower floors
broke the other dude notes that some of
the clients were in visitation with one
of the prisoners along with they select
few Heroes who have also been trapped
down there as the basement starts
twisting even more slowly reaching the
point where everyone might be crushed sa
tells tataki to stop treating people
like trash instead and to keep everyone
safe he grabs and pulls her in close to
his chest causing the esper to feel some
sort of way before forcefully jumping
Towards the Sky taking tataki with him
looking up through the gaping hole that
they just jumped through for notes that
it has begun scammer versus
tatsumaki above them the electric dude
can't even remember his name right now I
think it's lightning Max yells down
noticing the people there and calls over
to some other Heroes to head down
through this new gaping hole elsewhere
and the Maze that is this new hero
Association base tongue stretcher wolf
bear ballet and man eating kaby Bara
managed to escape from their holding
cell having made their way to what they
think is a random room The Three Goons
burst in expecting to find a few
pathetic humans they can eat instead
they find that it's not exactly weak
humans almost every single a Class Hero
is situated in this room hiding for some
reason dumbfounded with their luck the
monsters instantly close the door and
make a run for it elsewhere at the exact
same time a random family is seen
traveling towards their new condo at the
hero Association headquarters knowing
that the recent influx of monsters isn't
going to stop anytime soon the father
notes that the 35-year loan is a small
price to pay for them to live in peace
unable to even fathom how long 35 years
is the Sun just begins getting hyped up
over the thought of receiving signatures
from his like favorite Heroes once they
arrive suddenly a glint of light pierces
through the afternoon Sky confusing the
father who can't even see what it is of
course that sparkle in the sky was none
other than S Arma and tatsumaki who end
up crashing and bouncing along the
ground next to the highway tatsumaki
confusedly asks what the hell sitam is
up to before launching his body into a
violent spin whipping the cap body down
she slams him into the ground however
saitama's grip holds firm upon her arm a
flustered tatsumaki accuses saitama of
being into her but saitama corrects her
by stating that he just doesn't really
want her to run away and Destroy more
homes hearing him say run once more
makes tatsumaki explode in Anger as in
her mind why the hell would she run away
from someone weaker than her letting her
hand go now tataki instantly changes her
mood and even acknowledges sait's
strength saying that it isn't half bad
pulling her hand up to his forehead she
increases his psychic output just
slightly before flicking the Caped Baldi
sending him flying back into a pile of
rubble looking up Sait notices that
tajam Mari has completely lost it and
activated her signature tornado move
while everyone realizes that the two
guys have escaped the Suki yomi members
find their vehicle and boost past the
guards towards their freedom heavily
wounded and seemingly you know safe now
the Spy asks if Mr Apollo was all right
looking in the side mirror though he
quickly realizes that directly behind
them tatsumaki is already outside
seething with anger Apollo eily comments
that the next time he sees her she will
be his over in the battle tataki HS a
boulder directly at Sarma yet he easily
deflects it up in her attack potency
tataki sends a barrage of Boulders
towards him inside the control center of
the hero Association base a bunch of low
class workers relay in horror that
they've detected abnormal vibrations
approximately 2 km away from the base
overhearing the commotion and knowing
that middle Knight is still unreachable
and overseeing advisor asks for them to
begin assessing the disaster level based
off the minimal information he's heard
the advisor guesses that they probably
need an S-Class hero and asks if anyone
could be immobilized immediately
Outdoors you know that random family
who's trying to make their way to their
new condo start heading probably the
fattest StraightLine drifts I've ever
seen man is bringing back the saudy
drift King out from out of freaking
nowhere looking through his binoculars
and somehow still sitting in his seat
while the dad is doing the craziest
Maneuvers they could notice as the
amazing S-Class hero touch Mari fighting
a mysterious opponents of course the
dude flashing from rock to rock is none
other than the Bold Legend the father
who somewhat realizes how insanely
dangerous of a situation this is right
now remarks that they should probably
get away from here fast the kid though
who's wanting so bad to smoke a family
peack begs for his father to get in
closer as he can almost hear her voice
suddenly a massive Boulder is s
barreling towards the car luckily the it
manages to save the family by destroying
it in time annoyed he screams out to
tataki that she needs to pay attention
on what's going on around her asking him
why is acting so damn pompous tataki
swells her energy up and S another
flurry of Boulders while screaming that
she knows what she's doing seeing the
attack hitting his way and figuring that
she's probably not in the greatest of
moods sa comes to the conclusion that
for now he'll keep her company in the
desert where no buildings or people are
then eventually she'll wear herself out
having not paid enough attention though
alude accidentally deflects one of
tatsumaki's attacks into the direction
of that same f family Vanishing from
sight in an attempt to stop his own
deflection the car is then saved by this
small espert and pulled up into the sky
with her abilities instantly she turns
the situation on S hammer and jokes that
he needs to pay more attention when
deflecting things Furious he asks the
dumbass [__] what the hell she just
said to him literally Vin popping with
rage tataki screams that she's going to
turn the pathetic Bal into a vile of
farming fertilizer dropping the car to
the ground and leaving the family
absolutely Fred with what they just went
through the psychotic esper reactivates
her terrible tornado ability and begins
sending even more pieces of rubble in
the direction of our now fleeing B
curious as to why he's even fleeing now
she charismatically jokes that this is
pathetic there is no way she'd ever be
able to entrust Fuki to someone like him
telling him that he needs to leave and
get the hell away from her s scoffs it
just how bizarre this has all but thinks
all he wants to do right now is go home
with his motivation plummeting tataki
launches a psychic attack that blows off
saam's jacket not done she follows
follows up and sends forth a blast that
manages to knock the Caped body off his
feet flying across a random parking lot
sa is then hit by another few energy
attacks that sent him hurling miles
across the barren landscape towards the
closest city meanwhile back in the hero
Association headquarters and realizing
that now with tatsumaki making her
intentions clear there's no possible way
to keep her group together approaching
her with their heads down the Fuki group
all apologized to their leader for being
unable to do anything in the previous
battle they claim that if given another
a chance they will never make their
mistake again all she needs to do is
advise them on what to do about suomi
now and concerned for these weak cleans
Fuki just tells him she's done from
today the Fuki group is disbanded
because everyone else was too useless
standing there like stunned mullets all
the group is able to do is watch as Fuki
flies up into the sky telling him to
leave and not follow her meanwhile an in
City the a Class Hero feather is beaten
and heavily injured by a group of random
foes one of the gang memb joke that he
went a bit wild for a bit and did manage
to take a few of their guys down however
with the injuries feathers taken in the
process there's no way he can fight any
longer turns out fad only battled this
notorious ironfist gang with the
intentions of freeing a female hostage H
calling him an idiot for getting fooled
they ask the hero for any final words
only for the hero to ask about this
random girl's safety scoffing at just
how mentally deficient this hero is the
underling screams out for eica to show
herself turns out that feather already
knew this chick I wonder how many chicks
he knows and was actually being fooled
by her she was never his woman instead
Big Iron the boss of the iron first is
her man stunned and unable to take in
this cruel piece of information fither
can only listen as Erica explains about
the first time she was sent out as a
decoy to distract him from finding the
gang she thanks him for being so dumb he
couldn't pick up on her terrible acting
from the moment he met her while crying
she could see the intent on his face to
f fix the situation he truly is a model
hero yet she could barely even keep
herself from laughing laughing himself
now further notes that she is indeed
right she is one of the worst actors
he's ever met as tears then suddenly
begin dropping from her eyes big Iron
the man barges onto the scene and
questions as to why they're having so
much trouble with they singular rats
seeing that he's already on the verge of
collapse Big Iron threatens to finish
the a class off with a single shot
slowly rising to his feet and mentioning
that the this is perfect with no hostage
it means that he can fully let loose he
yells out and demands that Erica watch
this this this hair will be his climax
as a hero what the [__] did I just say
remixing the entire scuffle thether is
all of a sudden taken out by a flying
caped B who uncontrollably smashed
through the wall behind him looking at
the Burly boys all standing in front of
him sa on all fours quickly apologizes
for the damage but asks for them to send
the Bell to the lady behind him looking
over and seeing a bunch of guys on the
ground he yells out that someone should
probably call an ambulance for them as
everyone here is in terrible shape
jumping up into the cutout that sa made
when he entered the building the B tells
her that it's dangerous to blast him
through a building tataki though was
just like bro you're the one who ended
up blasting him through it his head back
and forth between each party because he
doesn't know where to talk to or who to
talk to or who to address the Baldi
screams that it's her fault for
launching him through the sky the group
themselves all just stand there sweeten
in fear as they know that standing
behind the Baldi the number two hero
touch some Mary the tornado of Terror
has entered their building instantly the
boss of the gang assumes feather broke
his promise and called the heroes out
here screaming out he tells his man that
a single S-Class hero isn't strong
enough to contend with them sa tries
telling him to chill but the boss you
know pounds down upon the a class Hero's
head only to instantly be
counterattacked by one of saam's basic
punches having watched the boss get sent
into the stratosphere Sait nonchalantly
asks who these guys are even meant to be
rushing forth all of the iron this gang
attempt to exact revenge for their boss
however tatsumaki demands that they all
shut it her and him are already in the
middle of a little something a little
while later we see that those dedly Iron
Fist members have all been taken care of
and feather has regained Consciousness
Erica mentions that the S-Class has
vanished just like a storm in the night
after dealing with the enemies slowly
making his own approach fether tries to
tell her that he was never tracked
instead it's probably best they forget
everything about the past so that now
she can be free like she wanted to
unconcerned for feather Erica mentions
that the one who saved her was tou Mary
and she needs to send a letter of
appreciation staring into the distance
fether knows that everything is now
resolved but he feels as if he was hit
by a car knowing that he said this fight
was going to be his climax F makes the
decision to return home and cry himself
to sleep in an attempt to forget this
day ever happened meanwhile in h City an
emergency evacuation is sounding letting
all of the civilians know about a nearby
monster that is suddenly appeared after
recent considerations this Monster's
disaster level has been adjusted from
demon to Dragon the warning recommends
that all Personnel Evacuate the entirety
of H City but pleads with them to remain
calm in these trying times as seen from
the chopper above the disaster level
Dragon monster kins and rat is
continuing its destructive Rampage so
far the Eastern portion of H city is
almost completely destroyed if this
keeps up then human civilization could
possibly be in danger at least that's
exactly how it feels if you're on the
ground situated like a reporter it's
also been reported that all police
firefighters and heroes who were in the
area have been completely wiped out
coming in to save the day though it's
been heavily reported through online
forums that the goat S-Class hero metal
bat is on the verge of making his
appearance in h City cheering for her
brother to make it there in time we
flash over to see a sweaty metal bat
boosting it towards the monster and
complaining about how he's going to miss
out on his precious cat having kittens
cuz how is it even possible possible
he's the only S-Class hero available
right now M notes that if something
happens to his cat he'll legit murk a
random civilian sliding into the
monsters line of sight middle calls out
to it and complains that because of this
damn thing arriving All Transport was
shut down and he's already had to run a
freaking Marathon just to get here
however before he even has the
opportunity to exact revenge on this rat
kinen is simply head shot and killed as
collateral damage in the battle between
saitam and tatsumaki screaming that he's
a stubborn loser tatsumaki proceeds to
throw saitam through another three
buildings coming to a stop at the other
side s tells the isper just to relax man
that the whole reason for coming out
here to start wor was to prevent damage
middle bat having stood there and
watched this entire altercation and just
not in the mood after sprinting all the
way to the scene decides to turn around
and go back home man wants to watch his
kittens remember how sweet mask was over
at that uh meeting shunning the bubbly
boys or whatever Well turns out that the
three buildings T Mari through Sama
through were directly opposite the
building mask was in noticing how far
they have gone from their original
location sa suggests to tataki that both
of them head back tatak at first seems
Cooperative dropping down and agreeing
with him but after he points out the
direction they should travel she
proceeds to grab saitama by his clean
shiny bald head and leads him back to
their original location by running his
head into the ground at the same time
looking back while being dragged sa
points out that there's something behind
them breaking into an inner monologue
tataki knows that if this thing behind
them is able to keep up with him it must
be a monster or some sort of hero turns
out the them behind them was the ball
banging Legend Speedo sound Sonic who
for some reason had a feeling that the
man being treated like a rag doll was
none other than sight Hammer UNC
concerned for the previous scuffle speed
throws a bunch of his weapons forth in
an attempt to finally end his rival's
life these special ninja shuriken
they've actually been specifically
engineered into a home in version that
will track its Target then explode
noticing them tataki nonch lightly
redirects all of the shuriken back at
the Ninja catching him completely by
surprise in an instant he begins dodging
each of his own attacks yet he fails to
notice a nearby dog poping on the floor
and accidentally steps in it losing his
balance speed [__] me man losing his
balance speed curses sight while
simultaneously getting hit by his own
exploding shurikens after seeing that
they're now back at their initial
location saama Breaks Loose from tatar's
grip astonishing her with his speed
before telling her that she can feel
free to Rampage here annoyed him for
looking down on her once more tataki
clarifies that she is actually the one
testing sight Arma and claims she should
go all out and put him in his place
literally chilling with his hand in his
pocket s then tells her to go all out on
him which once again surprises her back
inside of the hero Association
headquarters many frustrated members of
the blizzard group quit being Heroes
after fubuki's decision to break up
their group this is just mainly because
to them this group made them feel a part
of something bigger and stronger now
with no leader here they lack any
direction and aren't strong enough
themselves to compete with stronger
Heroes however eyelashes isn't done and
even manages to motivate a few loyal
remaining members to follow him as he
starts climbing towards the surface in
an attempt to find Fuki up on the
surface Fuki Witnesses tornadoes along
with a multitude of differing sized
Boulders smashing into and devastating
the landscape due to Tatam mari's
increased psychic outputs she screams
out to her sister that this this is too
much and she needs to stop but is
quickly forgotten about as tari beams s
through the sky over in the new base
King is seen at the entrance of sa's
apartment and is panicking due to the
surrounding catastrophe wondering where
s could possibly be at a time like this
a Bor Prophet suddenly shows up crashing
into the wall and telling King that he's
currently too busy to play fighting
games with him cuz he's dealing with
someone curious as to who he's fighting
King inquires only to find out that it's
this little pump squake tataki or
something having heard sarm make fun of
her tataki then Dives straight in for a
kick but misses and instead crashes into
to the wall as well of course King who
just happened to be standing there and
watching this catches a glimpse of Tatum
maki's underwear stunning him not
wanting to give his composure away King
just stands there looking composed and
ready for anything as tataki then Glides
back towards the bold man as the intense
Showdown continues to evolve it sends
even more Tremors in the direction of
the hero Association for ear having you
know like felt the Tremors wonder what
the hell is going on looking out the
window and scaring the absolute life out
of forte s a c dashes into the wall just
above his room confused he inquires as
to why he's out here prom his s to ask
him about how his injuries are healing
continuing to tell the young hero to
stay in bed the Caped BDI leaps from the
side of the building back towards the
midst of destruction after seeing the
destruction that his fellow a Class Hero
left to join Forte decides to wait a
while before his rematch with him after
arriving at the surface themselves the
remnants of the blizzard group is left
Gob smacked after seeing just how out of
control touch Mary is they know that if
they want to stick with fabuk though
they need to be marked by this Beast
swooping in over the C-Class Heroes
tajari knows that she ended up
miscalculating the outputed power of her
limits limit to start with she was meant
to be testing this guy yet it's all
flipped up on its head now up until now
in her life there was never truly been
an opponent that was able to take her
head on apart from obviously blast in
actuality she was enjoying this battle
as before it she assumed that the only
person capable of standing against her
was blast like I just said n to bring
this pointless show of strength to an
end tataki begins tearing up the ground
and contorting all of the rubble into
two large waves that Clash into each
other upon forming a tunnel likee
structure the isper then collapses it
upon the ant-sized man underneath but
even a fraction of a second later Sait
performs an effortlessly unharmed swing
throwing his arm up and dispersing all
of the rubble around him dropping to the
ground exhausted due to the psychic
output of that attack Z jokes that she
really didn't need to go and push
herself that far and she still have
enough strength to talk with with him at
the end of the day snapping at him the
esper catches s and an orb of her
psychic energy however he's so damn
heavy that she's barely able to even
pick him up off the floor asking why
she's looking so grumpy saama reiterates
that he isn't her enemy like he
mentioned before it's just she views the
lives of Human Relationships too Lightly
for example right now she's been stopped
by the power of ibuki's mere
acquaintance hearing those words and
after failing to send sarm into space
tatsumaki loses Consciousness from
overusing her power
dropping to her knees she starts to
remember how blast told her that she
shouldn't ever expect someone to come
and save her moments after blast had
saved her in the past tatsumaki
immediately reunited with Fuki in order
to protect her after noticing that she
was being followed by four suomi members
tataki disposed of them before once
again asking fi to come with her the
shock of witnessing her sister's violent
act caused the 5-year-old Fuki to awaken
her psychic power and push tatsumaki
away as the self-reflection of H
continues she comes to see that it was
her that dragged Fuki to a harsh fate
because of that she now feels like she
has the responsibility to protect her
without relying on anyone else actually
crazy when you think about it the reason
behind tataki wanting to constantly
protect her sister was because she was
the reason she developed powers in the
first place and now feels responsible
for people like possibly coming after
her and stuff Awakening in a bright
Place tataki sees blast standing in the
distance walking up to him she asks if
the this is where he's been all along
seeing him leave though she can't help
but run after him and plead for him not
to leave throughout the story so far the
only one to set tataki free was blast
due to this she grew an obsessive
excessive expectation of blast she saw
respect from the one that freed her and
needed someone to guide her on a better
Road catching up to him now tataki just
says that she tried really hard but
nothing ever works out she doesn't want
everyone to hate and be afraid of her
but if they aren't then things will just
end up how they were before standing
there with tears in her eyes she
questions the top ranking hero about
what she should do when suddenly an even
brighter beam of light begins catching
its way into this already glistening
realm of course she was just waking up
and above her was the gleaming Bal King
saama looking down and asking if she was
actually okay saitama Praises
tatsumaki's abilities and pets her on
the head while staying that if Tachi can
Rampage without destroying other
people's stuff then she would make a
great hero as saitama turns to leave
Fuki arrives and tells tataki she is
separated from her group like she asked
joking that she likes the new attitude
but it doesn't seem as if her own group
understands yet Fuki turns around to see
all of her loyal members running up
behind her see tataki glaring at the lot
of them eyelashes along with a few other
members Garner up the courage to ask if
she'll allow them to work below Fuki
done with these mice tataki raises her
hand to annihilate them however it's
Fuki who jumps in front and attacks who
own men with a hell storm blast knowing
that they came back here to confront
tatsumaki Fuki questions what the hell
they can even do when they can't even F
off a drastically weaker psychic power
actually confused with what the [__] is
going on right now sa and tatsumaki just
stand there watching the most neurod
Divergent C-Class scuffle they've ever
seen questioning what tari doesn't just
let them all go she just yeps back that
it's it's none of his concern not
listening saama continues that back
while he was job training he wasn't even
able to beat a wolf level threat before
starting proper muscle training right
now fubuki's team is all pathetically
weak however he thinks there is truly no
telling what their limits may be
agreeing with the statement tataki tears
her younger sister away and explains
that originally she came here to deal
with psychos in the end she overused too
much power on a random battle and
because of that has decided to let
everyone off the hawk for today on s's
request turning and glaring at the group
she exclaims that if anything does
happen to her sister then she will never
forgive them after hearing them all
agree she finally turns to Sait and
tells him that this test of theirs isn't
exactly over at any time whenever she
may feel like it she might show up and
surprise him with another test suffering
a level of depression not yet reached by
man sa disagrees is that's the last damn
thing he currently wants still nearby
and having listened Fuki is left blowing
away that her sister actually followed
his orders moments later S tails tataki
to chill out and not destroy anything
else before finally making his way back
to his house shooting up into the sky we
see that after the intense battle has
come to an end and the landscape was
destroyed apart from one minor hole in
the base the entire Association itself
remained unscathed having made the Long
Walk of Shame home sa enters his
apartment and comes to the conclusion
that he needs to get a new pair of shoes
and some clothes upon looking up though
he just like previously discovers that
three aass Heroes Forte butterfly DX and
chain and Toad are waiting for him
wondering what the hell they're doing
here now butterfly perks up and lets him
know that Forte has something to say
apologizing for their first meeting
Forte legit starts glazing sarm asking
if he needs any new clothes and if he
didn't mind he could bring some old
seats around for him creeped out with
his sudden switch up for tries to say
that it's because they're all a class
buddies and he's just trying to be
friendly with them sensing the
awkwardness the group makes the leave
still fory tells saitama that if
anything does bother him come and let
him know after the trio of Heroes
departed from saam's apartment butterfly
DX expressed his bewilderment over
Forte's abrupt change questioning if the
car knocked a different personality into
him knowing a greater secret though FL
disclosed that he witnessed s fighting
while at the hospital compared to them
his movements were out of this world and
he honestly doubts all three of them
would even last 10 seconds against him
in a true fight telling him to relax
Forte continues elaborating on how those
previous earthquakes weren't caused by
monsters it was the impact from his
fighting turning and pointing out the
pet he states that they better look
after them and do their best to get
sight armor on their
side at the demon level monster
containment level three a Class Heroes
Stinger lightning Max and blue arrived
to investigate the situation after
inspecting the mess lightning Max
assumes that most of the monsters on
this floor were wiped out by each other
blue who was also investigating couldn't
come to a solid conclusion on why the
association would take such risks
containing a bunch of dangerous monsters
below them
the Fuki group though tried to explain
to them that it wasn't a monster fight
and instead it was a single a Class Hero
who took them all out asking if they all
just saw something or are they dumb or
something they reiterate that they they
aren't they're telling the truth in the
meantime the other Fuki members confront
the executives of the hero Association
and accuse them of definitely knowing
something about suomi instead of fing up
the executives explained that they just
happened to have some spare time and
wanted to check the area out realizing
that they probably fell for a cruel [__]
G explains to the people around that
suomi is the name of a secret society
the only reason he even knows of it is
because there is an urban legend about
them inside of these psychic gossip
circles however he thinks that it's all
just a complete fast instead it makes
more sense for the surviving members of
the monster Association to come back and
kidnap their leader under the guise of
some new group with everyone somewhat
agreeing with his statement here Mr Fuki
calls out to Mr McCoy one of the
executives to have a chat about
something entering another room Fuki
confronts McCoy and asks him what the
hell is planning here if it wasn't for
her all of the members of her group
would have been turned into monster food
fing up McCoy goes on to detail that
they've been kidnapping monsters here
for a top secret weapon that is
currently being designed by metal bat
wanting more info though Fu raises a
document and asks what in the world this
massive sum of money paid to the
association was then sweating balls all
of a sudden over being found out fi's
genius hacker notes that the lines of
code he had are probably some of the
worst he's ever seen Fuki even jokes
that it would be such a scandal for the
world to find out about this news
immediately Mr McCoy drops his act and
asks what it is Fuki actually wants with
a grin of pleasure Fuki goes on to lay
out her devious plan pretty much she
wants to take all of the monsters that
have died turn the cams off and lay them
out on the surface that way Tatam maki's
Rampage can be marked off as both her
fighting against the demon level threat
plus if they manag to fix both of those
issues at once all of the rich folks
will gain some trust back in the
security of their house and this
structure here starting to cackle Mr Mr
McCoy agrees with fubuki's proposal and
tataki subsequently brought all of the
Monster remains to the surface as part
of the agreements however this actually
turned out to be a rose in itself as the
remains had a special someone imp
planted inside of them pulling up next
to a clump of monster flesh Fuki uses
her abilities to tear her old friend out
into the car following this the group
steps on the gas and accomplishes their
original goal they sit out to achieve
which you know was obviously going and
getting psychos from the hero
Association Bas and they did achieve the
Golem in simultaneously the news
broadcast of the incident brought
tatsumaki into the spotlight as
apparently she repelled all of these
Monsters by herself all of the city
literally everyone except one man was
overjoyed for this massive fate of
course saitama and subsequently his boy
Jos think this is complete crap Jos even
gets on the phone to file a major
complaint with the hero Association
immediately in the aftermath of this
incident the hero Association soon
discovered that psychos had actually
gone missing apparently she was able to
escape through a hole in the floor or
ceiling of a parking lot being called
there to answer for this tataki fed
responsibility and began searching for
this missing esur obviously you know she
made up a bunch of lies about her having
the ability to use her psychic powers to
track her psychic wavelengths and
everything anyway anyway what you knew
leave with a grin on his face Mr McCoy
calls out to her saying that he didn't
realize she could be oh so remorseful
full it's almost as if she's been
strangely kind to them turning and
looking more cooked than ever tataki
leaves saying that it's just some days
she happens to be in a good mood
meanwhile child Emperor who thought the
incident was kind of sussy to start with
did a little digging after a little
hacking into the hero Association base
he quickly came to see that the entire
incident was nothing but fraud and cover
ups and that there brings us to the very
end of the psychic sisters Arc obviously
there's a lot going on on this Arc we
had tataki versus SA which is the main
part of it but you know they didn't even
really you know have a proper bassle or
anything no one was properly mad at each
other even T Mari was having fun
throughout their battle as it kind of
like alluded to right at the end of it
and stuff it's really cool to see SAA
finally getting recognition for his
strength because he actually deserves it
you know he's done so much throughout
the series even though it doesn't say it
on his report card like Mr bofo
discovered he has done so much for like
the people in this Bas and stuff and
it's finally cool seeing people discover
that this random bold dude is insanely
strong and like all of the S-Class
Heroes foring over his strength
especially sweet mask seeing him and
being like man like he can't stop
looking at his phone I loved that it was
just hilarious it made drove me mad oh
just the the dating part of this art
there was so much good stuff I'd love to
know all of your favorite moments down
in the comment section below because
this was for a short art a banging one a
banging one and I can't wait to get into
the Neo Heroes AR so like I mentioned at
the side of the video as well push this
video to 30,000 likes which is an insane
amount that I've never asked for apart
from when I asked for 50,000 on the last
one but I don't ever think that'll be
achievable so 30,000 likes in the next
month and if we somehow get that on this
video then I guess we'll be going bold
by the time we probably uh put out the
Neo hero arcs video which uh will be
pretty interesting I think that's just
an introduction Arc so it doesn't have
too much at least I haven't read it yet
I always stop at the parts that I record
and then read more you know as I script
it and stuff because I don't want to
spoil myself and you know I enjoy series
and I don't want to like hop out of the
enjoyment factor of them by reading ahe
too far and then being like I don't want
to go back and do this so all the stuff
to me is always so enjoyable when it's
recent like yeah either way enough of me
rambling enough of me raming obviously
if you are new around here make sure you
hit the Subscribe button and if you do
want to get these videos extra early
like a day or two early before I do post
them up on YouTube then make sure to
check out my patreon which I will leave
down in the description below thank you
to all of the people who do support me
over there it's just you know it's
absolutely amazing getting the the
little extra cash to help out with
editors and all that kind of stuff so
and it it really really truly does help
with videos so thank you so much for all
of those guys over there either way
though for it's being your professional
degenerate deolo and I will see you all
in a bit bye